فيه قبل ايام من احياء لبنان
الذكرى السنوية الثانية للانفجار
دمرت ست راجمات صواريخ هايمارس
وثلاثة وثلاثين مدفع باوكرانيا.
للجفاف. كما وضعت السلطات قيودا
على استخدام المياه لاغراض غير
واشنطن قبل استعمال صواريخ
هايمرز الامريكية. شويجو قواتنا
الصيف ووضعت العاصمة باريس
وضواحيها القريبة في حالة تأهب
زيارة بيلوسي اعلن الاسطول
الامريكي السابع في تغريدة ان
اراضيها. هل ستكون بيلوسي باسوس
العصر وتتسبب بحرب لا تبقي ولا
تذر بخطوتها المستفزة للصين?
الاحداث والتطورات. الرئيس
الجزيرة التي تتمتع بحكم ذاتي
فيما تعتبرها الصين جزءا من
توعدت فيه الصين بشن اعمال
عسكرية محددة الاهداف ردا على
الامريكية. واشار المعهد البحري
الامريكي الى ان يو اس اس رونالد
الدفاع الروسية القوات الجوية
تقصف فيلق اجنبيا وتوقع مائتين
وخمسين من المرتزقة. المخابرات
الاوكرانية تكشف عن ضوء اخضر من
الظواهري في غارة جوية بطائرة
مسيرة بالعاصمة الافغانية.
الامريكية. فهل سيقتصر الرد
الصيني على اظهار القوة
المروع وغطى غبار كثيف اجواء
مرفأ بيروت فور انهيار الجزء
عسكرية وانشطة تدريبية مهمة بما
في ذلك تدريبات بالذخيرة الحية
الامريكي نانسي بيلوسي لتايوان
استفزازا سافرا يأتي في سياق
حاملة الطائرات يو اس اس رونالد
ويجن التي تجوب المنطقة منذ
اوكرانيا تعاني فرنسا من موجة حر
قاسية هي الثالثة منذ بداية
اسبانيا تتراجع عن تسليم دبابات
ليوبارد في حالة يرثى لها الى
سفينة الامداد في الوقت نفسه
تجولت سفينة برمائية تابعة
تايوان بالتزامن مع وصول رئيسة
مجلس النواب الامريكي نانسي
عسكريا? حليف الروسي. الحليف
الروسي للصين ادان زيارة بيلوسي
المتصدع. خطاب شديد اللهجة تبديه
بكين تجاه الاستفزازات
والتدريبات والمناورات العسكرية
ام انها ستشن فعلا عملية عسكرية
للسلاح البحري وهي طرابلس في شرق
تايوان وفقا للمعهد البحري
النهج العدواني الامريكي الرامي
الى ردع الصين. واضاف بيان
بيلوسي الى الجزيرة وفقا مصادر
عسكرية امريكية. وفي الوقت الذي
الامريكي يو اس ان اي وهو منظمة
مستقلة لكنها قريبة من البحرية
فيجن ويو اس اس طرابلس كلاهما
حاملة لاحدث من طائرات اف خمسة
وثلاثين بدورها اكدت ان زيارتها
تظهر التزام واشنطن القوية حيال
للخارجية الروسية نعتبر العلاقة
بين الجانبين على مضيق تايوان
البحرية الامريكية صورا ليو اس
اس رونالد فيجن وهي تقوم مع
مؤكدة ان الجيش الصيني في حالة
قتالي وكتبت صحيفة جلوبال تايمز
بداية يوليو موجودة في بحر
الفلبين جنوب تايوان. ونشرت
الضرورية لحماية سيادة ووحدة
الاراضي فيما يخص قضية تايوان.
الامريكي جو بايدن يعلن مقتل
زعيم تنظيم القاعدة ايمن
الامريكية الخطيرة للغاية. وقالت
في بيان ان واشنطن تعمل على
موسكو المشغولة بحرب اوكرانيا.
هل ستقف مع بكين عسكريا في حال
الصينية على تويتر سيجري جيش
التحرير الشعبي الصيني مناورات
في ست مناطق محيطة بجزيرة تايوان
من الخميس حتى الاحد. التوتر
تفريغ مبدأ الصين الواحدة وتوعدت
بشن عمليات عسكرية محددة الهدف.
ضرورية. انهار جزء متصدع من مرفأ
بيروت بعد تكرر اندلاع النيران
لتايوان اذ اعتبرت الخارجية
الروسية زيارة رئيسة مجلس النواب
تايوان قبل وصول بيلوسي بقليل.
واستنكرت بكين التصرفات
التايواني جوزيف وو. تصعيد بكين
العسكري. بكين جاء سريعا اذ افاد
الاستفزاز الامريكي وامريكا تحرك
حاملات الطائرات الامريكية في
الصيني الامريكي يتصاعد فهل
ستجرأ الصين على اجتياح تايوان
نانسي بيلوسي الى تايوان. واظهرت
صور مباشرة وصولها الى مطار سونج
شان في تايباي بطائرة عسكرية.
وكان في استقبالها وزير الخارجية
المتكررة وصلت مساء الثلاثاء
رئيسة مجلس النواب الامريكي
للواجهة. فما الذي حدث؟ امريكا
تلعب بالنار. في تحد امريكي خطير
قد يجر العالم نحو حرب عالمية
ثالثة ورغم التحذيرات الصينية
نانسي بيلوسي تحرج بكين وتزور
تايوان رغم التهديدات الصينية
وبكين تحرك طائراتها واسطولها
لتطويق تايوان وتتوعد بشن عملية
شأنا داخليا للصين. ومن حق
الجانب ان يتخذ كافة الاجراءات
اجتياحها تايوان? رد امريكي.
جابت سفن امريكية عدة منطقة
ماذا ستفعلون؟ نحن هنا اين انتم؟
هكذا قالها بايدن متحديا الصين.
التليفزيون الصيني ان مقاتلة من
طراز سو خمسة وثلاثين عبرت مضيق
فرنسا تشتعل وتمنع استخدام
المياه ومأساة انفجار بيروت تعود
عسكرية. الهي ما كل هذا التصعيد؟
روسيا تؤيد حليفها الصيني وتدين
بحر الفلبين وتعلن مقتل شخص ارق
امنها لعقود فمن هو هذا الشخص؟
وكانها تقول لن تنفعكم طائراتكم
ولا اسلحتكم ايها الصينيون.
تجتاح تايوان.